Now, if you've been around software engineering long enough, you'll realize that
most of the technology that makes up the web isn't really new or cutting edge.
It's actually old technologies with new, sometimes worse names. Now, I think
Atlases and spreadsheets are a perfect point of this. So a spreadsheets in the
HTML5 world actually describes that what we use an Atlas. But this is very, very
wrong. See back in the 2D days of making games. Atlases were used to define many
sorts of charts in a single image, where spreadsheets was a term reserved just
for animated objects. The spreadsheet concept only really existed when you
needed particles to fly around or a character to make a swipe with his sword,
everything else was just an Atlas. Now, for you web developers out there who are
actually using the term spreadsheet incorrectly, I forgive you. But let's try to
fix that, okay?